a reminder of why big data remains a big
deal today frances halgan a former
facebook product manager testified
before u.s lawmakers as a whistleblower
she was armed with company documents to
back her claim that facebook and
instagram can be addictive and harmful
to children part of her message
facebook's ceo mark zuckerberg has
always been aware of the dangers
choosing to put astronomical profits
over the welfare of people now to
understand this haugen described a
business model designed to ensure that
content gets our attention and keeps us
coming back the more engagement the more
advertising revenue profits are pushed
ever higher bonuses for facebook
executives get bigger and bigger now
this is part of haugen's opening
statement delivered earlier today
i joined facebook because i think
facebook has the potential to bring out
the best in us
but i'm here today because i believe
facebook's products harm children stoke
division and weaken our democracy
the company's leadership knows how to
make facebook and instagram safer but
won't make the necessary changes because
they have put their astronomical profits
before people
congressional action is needed
they won't solve this crisis without
your help
yesterday we saw facebook get taken off
the internet i don't know why i went
down but i know that for more than five
hours facebook wasn't used to deepen
divides
destabilize democracies and make young
girls and women feel bad about their
bodies
it also means that millions of small
businesses weren't able to reach
potential customers
and countless photos of new babies
weren't joyously celebrated by family
and friends around the world
i believe
in the potential of
facebook we can have social media we
enjoy
that connects us
without tearing our democr apart our
democracy putting our children in danger
and sowing ethnic violence around the
world
we can do
better there was a lot of discussion
today about social media's algorithms
and how artificial intelligence is used
to calibrate the content that gets
humans hooked not surprisingly we heard
that hate speech and images of violence
guarantee the most clicks and the most
traffic our ugliest tendencies drive the
data for adults and for kids
please explain to me ms haugen
how these ads uh
with a target audience
of 13 to 17 year old children
how would they possibly be approved by
facebook and is ai involved in that it
is very possible that none of those ads
were seen by a human and the reality is
that we've seen from repeated documents
within my disclosures is that facebook's
ai systems only catch a very tiny
minority of offending content and best
case scenario in the case of something
like hate speech at most they will ever
get 10 to 20 percent in the case of
children that means drug paraphernalia
adds like that uh
it's likely if they rely on computers
and not humans they will also likely
never get more than 10 to 20 percent of
those ads
we want to talk about that now to do
that i'm joined by chris messerl
director of research for the artificial
intelligence and emerging technology
initiative at the brookings institution
he joins me tonight from washington
chris it's good to have you on the
program this this reliance
on artificial intelligence as we heard
today it can lead us to some very dark
places are we relying too much on
artificial intelligence especially on
social media
yeah first of all thank you for having
me and it's a great question and i think
really in many ways the question of our
times is is the reliance of our society
on ai to drive the information that we
are exposed to and to
uh inform the citizenry about uh what's
happening in the world around us uh and
unfortunately in many cases you know the
ai that has been unleashed on facebook
and other other platforms what it's
learned is that you know individuals um
if you know if the company is trying to
maximize engagement that
individuals using their platforms
are much more likely to engage with
material that is inflammatory that is
divisive
and that
you know elicits a strong emotional
response and so sometimes that could be
good things you know if it's a picture
of your your family uh you know and your
makes you very happy right um but
other times and i think this is what
haugen was trying to get to in her
testimony today is that there's also a
much darker undercurrent to that kind of
engagement and it's one that
we as a society i think really need to
begin to grapple with um as ai learns
more about how to stimulate us and drive
our engagement towards kind of the
darker reachers of humanity so to speak
um what it would require i would say on
facebook's end is just a greater
transparency uh into how their ai works
which is again is the point that um ms
hogan was making today which is that you
know if ai is really the problem here
you know what we need to do is get a
much better understanding of actually
how it works um and hopefully her her
hearing you know the hearing she
testified in will help to galvanize
support towards greater transparency
over time
let's talk a little bit about mark
zuckerberg the facebook ceo he has had a
a rocky relationship
with the us congress to say the least
haugen said that
he is ultimately to blame for facebook's
problems take a listen to what she said
today
mark zuckerberg ought to be looking at
himself in the mirror today
and yet rather than taking
responsibility
and showing leadership
mr zuckerberg is going sailing there's
no one currently holding mark
accountable but himself and mark
zuckerberg in effect is the algorithm
designer in chief correct i received an
mba from harvard and they emphasize to
us that we are responsible for the
organizations that we build the buck
stops with him the buck stops with him
chris do you agree does the buck really
start stop with mark zuckerberg
i mean is there real accountability
here when we're talking about this this
be a moth of a company
yes i mean i i think of all the points
that was made today and i was raised
today i think that's probably the most
accurate in terms of the criticisms
leveled at facebook is that
mark zuckerberg has a controlling share
of the board i think he has 55 of the
the shares of facebook or the the voting
shares of facebook
and as a result he is literally
unaccountable to anyone most you know
competing platforms and other large
companies their ceos um are accountable
to a board that can hold them um you
know and kind of pressure them to do the
right thing in many cases um but with
mark zuckerberg he's not uh and so you
know later in their testimony um miss
hugging kind of mentioned the fact that
um you know at one point in time mark
zuckerberg was explicitly made aware of
the way in which the myanmar military
was using uh the you know facebook's uh
platform uh to carry out uh ethnic
violence um and the response was to do
nothing and so you know i think um
her point that the the buck stops with
mark zuckerberg is a valid one both
because he has the controlling power and
because
within you know the role that he has
he's been made aware of what's happening
on the platform and yet things don't
seem to change
what about parents i mean parents
listening to today's
hearing
you know justifiably should be alarmed
maybe even frightened um
what should parents take away from what
we learned today
you know i think um as a parent myself i
think the the main thing
you know parents should take away
is that you know these platforms and
facebook in particular it's a great way
of connecting with others staying in
close touch with family for example for
instance but it can also be used uh to
manipulate um and to you know create
harm especially for children and that
the the the product itself is really
just not mature enough yet
to be able to reliably and consistently
deliver content to children
in a way that
won't lead them into categories of
either self-harm or
you know self-doubt things like that
related to body image in particular and
so
for parents who are trying to navigate
these apps and figure out you know
whether their children should be on
these platforms
you know i think especially for younger
children it's really hard to watch
today's hearing and come away thinking
you know yeah it'll be great for for
kids to to spend a lot of time on
facebook kids or on instagram for kids
it's just
it's it's hard to see how any parent
would draw that connection from the
hearing this morning and you know at the
same time um facebook's growth
is actually slowing uh young people i
mean if you ask your kids i'm sure
that's they'll tell you that facebook is
for old people we know that facebook
needs new users
can you imagine
facebook with a kinder gentler business
model
you know it's it's one where you know i
one thing that they could do would just
be to take out comments and only only
make it possible to you know have you
know positive comments but they've tried
you know different platforms have tried
that
it's really
it doesn't seem to be working for
facebook and the way that it might for
other platforms and so they've really
struggled to create
a family of apps that can work for
children and be gentle and kind um
consistently and reliably deliver the
kind of experience that i think most you
know most parents would want for their
children so it's um you know i imagine
facebook may answer differently but i
have a hard time seeing how that would
be possible at this point and it's going
to hurt them in the long run it's going
to be a challenge for them to maintain
their relevance that they've had for the
past decade yeah and i can imagine too
parents are conflicted i'm sure a lot of
parents have their you know retirement
funds partially invested in facebook
shares you know what to do big questions
there chris messerl director of research
for the artificial intelligence and
emerging technology initiative at the
brookings institution chris we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
thank you so much